[Music]
tributes to a son
and brother shakur pinnock died six days
after a collision with a car
whilst riding an electric scooter in
wolverhampton
his girlfriend who was seriously injured
in the crash was his passenger
she was brought to see him in her own
hospital bed
her twenties shack was celine fraser
pinock's youngest child
she'd worry every time he left the house
and on friday she was with him as he
died
i'm trying to think how he lived but not
the way he went
so i know and i'm not guilty of anything
that i know he's lived
a fulfilled life he knows i love him he
knows his family loves him
which is great and i was there with him
to the end
and i tried everything that i could
possibly do
shaq's e-scooter was privately owned an
investigation is underway into
what happened but it's illegal to ride
one on the roads unless it's hired as
part of one of the many trials being
carried out up and down the country
like this one in oxford you have to be
18 or over to hire one of these
and have a provisional driving license
at the very least
then you just download an app pay a
pound
and then it's 20p a minute the legal top
speed is 15.5 miles per hour
they mustn't be ridden on pavements but
you don't have to wear a helmet
only on saturday a 55 year old man came
off an e-scooter he'd hired in newcastle
and suffered a serious head injury he's
not known if he was wearing one
but shaq's older brother hamadi thinks
helmets should be obligatory
i definitely 100 think that you should
need need to be
a law just to say that you need your
protective equipment
because the injuries that he suffered
the worst was to the head
the arm the lungs and everything was all
healable he could have pulled through
but it was the injuries of the head
that's what got him the most
break the law on an e-scooter and you
could be
fined or get points on your license but
if something goes wrong
there's much more at stake as shaq's
family knows only too well
emma birchley sky news